surprise animal crossings 2.0 update is
out a little earlier than expected this
free content update adds a ton to the
game and if you've been eagerly waiting
like i have you'll want to get
everything you can right away but
remember this is animal crossing which
means the game is going to force you to
wait for stuff to unlock first meaning
you'll want to make sure to take care of
a few things right away so you can for
example unlock brewster's cafe as soon
as possible so if you haven't dived in
yet we got the lowdown on what to
prioritize
first thing you'll want to do is head
over to resident services and spend a
lot of time over at the abd hopefully
you'll have saved up those nook miles
because you'll have a lot to purchase
right away you'll want to buy all of the
upgrades you can unlock instantly that
would be the island life 101 service ba
chef diy recipes plus pro camera app
custom designs patterns plus pro
decorating license custom fencing and a
flash new reactions notebook and top 4
rad hairstyles there are also a few new
recipes if you're lucky one or both of
the two daily fence recipes will be one
of the nine new fences available
additionally there is a recipe for a
large wooden shed which will allow you
to access home storage from anywhere on
your island lastly there is a donation
box recipe which can act as a tip jar
for visitors only the island owner can
collect donations from the donation box
now it's time to check out all the new
items you can purchase with nook miles
because there are a bunch if it's been a
minute since you've made a lot of
purchases it's worth remembering that
you can only order 5 shippable nook mile
items per day so choose wisely and order
all 5 items to maximize your collection
i recommend picking up the abd if you
want a second atm on your island right
away there is also the storage shed
available for purchase but you can also
build the wooden storage sheds using the
recipe and save a slot for another nook
mile item next you'll want to talk to
isabel and set up your island ordinance
you have four options beautiful island
makes your villagers help pick up weeds
and water flowers and is a great choice
if you're tired of dealing with the
daily maintenance of your island early
bird wakes up your villagers and opens
up all the shops early and is perfect
for players who like to get their animal
crossing time in the morning before work
school night owl does the opposite
keeping the shops open and villagers up
later and is perfect for someone like me
who gets most of my animal crossing time
in at night
last is bell boom which increases how
much items sell for but also increases
how much items cost this is best for
those of you looking to focus on making
more money an ordinance change costs 20
000 bells and you'll have to wait until
the next day for it to take effect
finally talk to tom nook about upgrading
your storage space the first of three
storage upgrades starts at 700 000 bells
and will take a day to go into effect so
buy that now if you've got the cash you
can also check out the new house
customization options but keep in mind
you can't do both the house
customization and the storage upgrade on
the same day so you'll need to pick one
now that we've taken care of that head
out and make a quick stop by nook's
cranny you'll be able to purchase the
latter setup kit recipe and basic cook
recipes however that's pretty much it
okay i know you're all itching to get
the cafe open but it's gonna take at
least two days so you'll want to start
right away head over to the museum and
talk to blathers he'll ask you to find
brewster so you can get the cafe open no
one knows where brewster is but blathers
hints that he's likely looking for
gyroids which can be found on an island
that cap'n will take you to so head over
to your dock and talk to captain cap'n
only offers one tour a day so it's
important you talk to blathers about
brewster first as long as you did this
you should find brewster right away on
the first island cap and takes you talk
to brewster and he'll tell you to return
to blathers make sure to pick the island
clean and dig up some gyroids while
you're there after you return to
blathers he'll start preparing for
brewster's arrival tomorrow the museum
will close for construction and then the
following day the cafe will finally open
the final thing we need to take care of
on your first day is setting up the new
shopping plaza which is another
multi-day process
grab 100 000 bells and then head over to
harvest island he and harriet will give
you the spiel on the plaza and then you
are free to pick which of these seven
merchants you'd like to set up first
including leaf red
kix sahara and new merchants tortimer
katrina and reese and cyrus each shop
costs a donation of 100 000 bells and
you can only build one a day if you are
interested in the new cooking recipes i
highly recommend setting up leaf first
as he is the only way to get the crops
you need to start your garden make sure
to return to harvest every day and
donate for a new shop after the first
day an abd will be added letting you
withdraw money on the island so you no
longer need to worry about bringing it
with you anymore after the first shop is
set up harriet will open her salon
station once a day she will offer you a
free hairstyle even if you don't like
the look she gives you and ask to revert
it back the new style will still unlock
permanently as an option at a vanity or
mirror and that right there is
everything you want to take care of so
you can get access to all of your new
shops and goodies right away if you
found this helpful give this video a
like and sub to gamespot because we
aren't done yet we'll have plenty more
guides for happy home paradise on the
way that you won't want to miss